[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
j'espère que le week-end a été bon comme
d'habitude de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie au
programme on regarde tout de suite le
sommaire de ce lundi 22 mai
face à la pénurie de candidats
l'éducation nationale cherche des
enseignants contractuels l'académie de
Versailles première de France avec plus
d'un million d'élèves organisons toute
la semaine et des journées de
recrutement pour embaucher de nouveaux
professeurs des écoles nous y avons
assisté cet après-midi le détail dans
les infos du jour
jusqu'à la fin du festival de Cannes TV
78 grâce à Radio sensation vous emmène
sur la Croisette comme chaque année la
région Île-de-France est présente sur
place un territoire phare pour
l'industrie cinématographique en
Île-de-France 68% des entreprises de
production française sont basées dans la
région c'est également ici que la
majorité des tournages de l'Hexagone
sont réalisés
et puis le sport avec une fin de saison
idyllique pour Chevreuse le club de
rugby est assuré de jouer la saison
prochaine en Fédérale 3 et poursuit
actuellement son parcours dans les
phases finales de régional une les
Yvelinois se sont qualifiés pour les 8e
de finalière après leur victoire
renversante face à Créteil retour sur
cette rencontre dans le 7 8
et le rugbylinois qui est décidément à
la fête trois clubs évolueront la saison
prochaine dans le championnat de fédéral
de le sixième échelon national aux côtés
de plaisir et Versailles désormais le
MLS GP qui fait son retour dans cette
Fédérale 2 le club de MLSGP maison
Lafitte Saint-Germain-en-Laye et Poissy
pour vous détailler bien sûr ce sigle
qui a donc validé son ticket hier après
son succès contre Cavaillon en 16e de
finale de Fédérale 3 le président du MLS
GP est avec nous en plateau il s'agit de
Jacques Boine bonsoir bonsoir alors au
lendemain justement de cette validation
de ce ticket en fédéral 2 comment vous
sentez soulager soulager il y a eu une
pression qui a été lourde tous ces
derniers mois parce qu'en fait
toute la saison se décide sur quelques
minutes en fin de compte on est beaucoup
de gens en place l'investissement humain
des joueurs qui donnent et pour tous
décident
sur un coup de ballon quoi on a perdu
l'année dernière la dernière minute vous
étiez tout proche voilà la dernière
minute donc on a recommencé on a remis
le bleu de chauffe comme on dit et puis
cette année ça nous sourit et donc on
retrouve
avec en ville niveau fédéral 2 on aura
l'occasion d'en parler tout à l'heure il
y a aussi un joueur qui vous accompagne
et qui sera présent avec nous tout à
l'heure dans la partie sport et dans la
partie sport justement on va parler d'un
rôle essentiel dans le sport celui
d'entraîneur celui qu'on appelle plus
connu communément coach avec vous
Rodrigue mbezi bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
vous coach l'Étoile Sportive de Trappes
un coach engagé puisque vous venez de
publier un livre qui s'appelle je suis
coach depuis le début on aura l'occasion
d'en parler aussi tout à l'heure en
quelques mots il retrace votre le
parcours et il donne des clés ce livre
pour atteindre ces objectifs et vous le
rappelez régulièrement dans le livre le
mot clé finalement c'est la
détermination on peut arriver avec
beaucoup de choses à beaucoup de choses
avec la de la détermination oui tout à
fait moi j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
avoir été accompagné dans mon parcours
de jeunes éducateurs et puis bah ce
parcours a permis d'apprendre pas mal de
choses et surtout que quand on se donne
les moyens on arrive à faire de grandes
choses donc c'est clair que le mode
détermination est très très important
pour moi on en parlera aussi tout à
l'heure dans cette édition et puis
attrape toujours talent trap chaud un
tremplin pour les humoristes locaux qui
se déroulent ce mercredi soir au
Conservatoire de Musique et de Danse il
est organisé notamment par vous Alain
Degois bonsoir papi oui on vous connaît
sur le territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines
comme papi artiste associé de la ville
de trap et aussi surtout fondateur de la
compagnie Déclic Théâtre qui fait
d'ailleurs cette année c'est 30 ans
Jamel Debbouze Sofia ara Marnot de sa
mère le ripéré ou encore Issa Doumbia
pour citer quelques noms qui ont fait
leurs premières armes au sein de de la
compagnie en quelques mots quel est le
concept de trappe de talons trapon aura
l'occasion d'en parler un peu plus tout
à l'heure et ben oui alors on en parlera
tout à l'heure mais non c'est c'est
donner l'occasion aussi à de jeunes
personnes qui veulent se lancer sur une
un plateau de se retrouver devant un
public de pouvoir se donner à voir se
faire entendre et puis une singularité
peut-être à j'adore ça moi les
singularités donc accompagner des
singularités à émerger peut-être vous
allez animer la soirée du coup oui bien
sûr j'accompagne on a eu l'occasion
récemment dans le 7 8 humour qui a été
proposé sur TV 78 notamment et dans un
instant également les informations du
jour sera avec vous Gabriel Gontier
bonsoir et ce sera juste après les
prévisions météo qu'on va regarder tout
de suite pour demain
[Musique]
le temps devrait se dégrader légèrement
demain matin dans les Yvelines un ciel
nuageux est annoncé il fera 14 degrés
dans le nord et l'ouest du département
13 degrés à l'est et au sud quelques
rayons de soleil pourraient faire leur
apparition être dans l'après-midi côté
température prévoyez à 18 degrés à
Versailles et ou dans 19 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 20 degrés à
Rambouillet et demain on fête les Didier
sur les informations du jour dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
suite c'est donc avec vous qu'on va voir
ces informations ce qu'il faut retenir
de ce lundi 22 mai dans les Yvelines
avec Gabriel avec un événement qui a
débuté aujourd'hui dans l'académie de
Versailles oui Grégory l'académie de
Versailles prépare la rentrée 2023 avec
une large session de recrutement
première employeur d'Île-de-France
l'Académie recrute des professeurs des
écoles contractuelles dans le premier
degré les premiers entretiens ont débuté
aujourd'hui et ils vont se poursuivre
jusqu'au 26 mai sont éligibles toutes
les personnes titulaires d'un Bac + 3 ce
dispositif s'inscrit dans l'engagement
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale
d'améliorer les conditions d'exercice du
métier et de palier le manque de
professeur je vous propose qu'on écoute
Charline Avenel rectrice de l'académie
de Versailles les conditions de
rémunération d'attractivité ont été
améliorées par exemple l'année dernière
lorsqu'on était contractuel on signait
un contrat pour un an cette année on le
signe pour deux ans la rémunération a
été augmentée on est autour de 2000
euros pour un contractuel en tout début
de carrière
ces améliorations ont fait venir de
nombreux candidats comme cette jeune
femme venue passer un entretien j'étais
dans le passé remplaçant dans une école
donc ça m'a motivé beaucoup plus de
participer aujourd'hui je veux
participer dans le développement des
élèves tout ça c'est pour ça je suis ici
le statut a décontractuel avait fait
l'objet de nombreuses critiques l'année
dernière pour la première fois les
personnes recrutées seront formées deux
fois avant et après la rentrée elles
seront également accompagnées au cours
de l'année par des tuteurs auront des
formations et un accès à des ressources
pédagogiques à ce sujet le collectif on
veut des profs qui rassemblent des
parents d'élèves mécontents des absences
non remplacées de professeurs à lancer
une deuxième action collective en
justice contre les tailles demandent un
dédommagement de préjudice et l'embauche
de professeur à Versailles toujours
aujourd'hui Gabriel s'ouvre la première
session de billetterie pour le moins
Molière oui le Mois Molière revient pour
sa 27e édition alors comme chaque année
l'événement propose des places de
spectacle gratuite appris réduit le but
Grégory rendre le théâtre accessible à
tous l'événement se déroulera tout le
mois de juin cette année la billetterie
se fait en deux phases en deux sessions
la première a ouvert aujourd'hui à midi
la seconde aura lieu le 6 juin mais
attention il faudra être rapide si vous
souhaitez prendre des places car très
prisé elle s'écoute elle s'écoule
parfois en mois de 24 heures vous pouvez
retrouver les programmations sur le site
internet moi molière.com cette année des
créations originales seront proposées en
avant-première avant de partir pour le
Festival of d'Avignon l'événement
devrait accueillir cette année encore
plus de 150000 personnes autre
information elle concerne la déclaration
de revenus oui depuis le 13 avril la
déclaration de revenus 2022 est ouverte
mais vous avez jusqu'à ce soir minuit si
vous souhaitez faire votre déclaration
de revenus en format papier alors si ce
n'est pas fait pas de panique vous
pouvez encore opter pour le format
numérique en vous rendant sur le site
impôts gouv.fr mais ne tardez pas trop
quand même vous avez jusqu'au 8 juin
pour faire votre déclaration de revenus
dans les nos invités étaient spectateurs
si on la prend en ligne on a encore un
délai supplémentaire après Le Vésinet
Magny-les-Hameaux ou encore Poissy une
nouvelle commune yvelinoise passe à une
limitation de vitesse à 30 km/h les
automobilistes de Fontenay-le-Fleury
devront lever le pied la vitesse
maximale autorisée dans la ville est
passé à 30 km/h devenant une ville zone
30 mais pas dans son intégralité Grégory
la RD11 et la rd127 reste à 50 km/h du
côté du village et du périmètre autour
de l'église la vitesse la vitesse est en
revanche abaissée à 20 km/h dans les
zones de rencontres l'objectif de ce
changement obtenir une circulation plus
apaisée et limiter les risques
d'accident et on termine avec le chiffre
du jour qui concerne le zoo safari de
Thoiry oui un chiffre Grégory qui est
presque record le zoo safari de Thoiry à
littéralement été pris d'assaut ce
weekend près de 8000 visiteurs étaient
présents samedi alors il faut croire que
la combinaison du week-end de
l'Ascension et du beau temps à profiter
au parc en début de journée la fille de
voiture devant l'entrée était déjà
importante alors jusqu'à près d'une
heure d'attente pour certains après les
propos recueillis par nos confrères du
Parisien une influence qui a même créé
des bouchons sur une partie de la
départementale qui longe le zoo le
record d'entrée du parc c'était à 8500
personnes donc il a presque été atteint
merci beaucoup Gabriel pour ces enfants
et comme d'habitude si vous aussi après
de chez vous voyez une actualité qui
vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas à la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news
et direction tout de suite le 60/6
Festival de Cannes avec aujourd'hui la
région et Île-de-France à l'honneur la
majorité des tournages en France se
déroule sur le territoire et
l'Île-de-France ne manque pas d'atout
pour dynamiser le secteur c'était
d'ailleurs le sujet d'une récente
conférence sur la Croisette on retrouve
sur place Martin patrie de nos confrères
de radio sensation
68% des entreprises de production
cinématographiques sont aujourd'hui
situées en Île-de-France une région qui
regroupe des entreprises des talents et
un savoir-faire résultat plus de la
moitié des tournages français ont lieu
en Île-de-France où ils génèrent plus de
150 000 emplois et forcément des
retombées économiques écoutez Johanna
Gallardo responsable de l'écosystème à
film par région il le fera c'est une
région très riche une région les plus
riches d'Europe mais c'est une énorme
activité une activité très importante
voilà on a plus de 6 milliards de PIB
qui est lié à la filière image dans
l'ensemble on a 6700 entreprises qui
sont basées il y a plus de 70% de
l'activité tournage qui se passe en
Île-de-France et les grands les sièges
sociaux des grands groupes audiovisuels
sont ni le front donc c'est c'est très
important et en plus c'est une région
qui est très attractive en termes
d'images puisqu'elle a la Tour Eiffel le
château de Versailles enfin des lieux
iconiques qui sont très utilisés dans le
cinéma chaque année la région
Île-de-France à louer près de 25
millions d'euros au secteur du cinéma il
y a l'audiovis elle soutient également
en plus de 150 films et une quarantaine
de scénaristes par an cette année 19
films mis à l'honneur au Festival de
Cannes ont été en partie financés par la
Région des investissements qui ont pour
principal objectif de soutenir l'emploi
du secteur donc en donnant de l'argent à
des productions pour que les films se
fassent et ben du coup on embauche des
techniciens en embauche des acteurs on
paye des prestations et des entreprises
donc voilà donc ça bénéficie à l'emploi
mais ça bénéficie aussi à son image et
notamment à l'image touristique et
envoie une série comme emilyn Paris ce
qui est un carton sur la plateforme
Netflix à tirait énormément de touristes
alors Paris et l'Île-de-France est déjà
une région très touristique mais il y a
des quartiers il y a des tours emilyn
Paris même Lupin aussi donc ça voilà
c'est ces productions qui intègrent dans
les décors l'Île-de-France participe à
son image enfin attractivité en termes
d'image et donc autorisant 1 € d'aide
régionale génère entre 7 et 16 euros de
retombées économique pour notre région
un petit tour de table mais papi n'a pas
le droit de participer si je vous dis
trap et talent humoristique quels on
vous vient à l'esprit un profamini
peut-être
autour de l'humour
Jamel Debbouze le premier mot le premier
nom qui à qui vous vient
de talent trap chaud qui se déroule je
disais en début d'édition ce mercredi 24
mai c'est au conservatoire de musique et
de danse et de Trappes le début est à
20h30 vous le voyez sur cette affiche
donc c'est un tremplin humour vous lisez
tout à l'heure papi mettant en lumière
les humoristes locaux un territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines quand même
faut le dire avec un réservoir énorme de
talent Jamel Debbouze sophiara Marnot de
sa mère Laurie Péret il sa Doumbia on
les cité tout à l'heure comment vous
expliquer qu'il y a une telle richesse
de talent sur le territoire je suis là
l'explication c'est c'est on en parle
aussi pour le sport c'est pareil c'est
comment on accompagne des des jeunes que
ce soit quelle que soit le talent
sportif on en reparlera avec les nos
camarades tout à l'heure mais et je
crois qu'il y a un terroir ici qui est
fait autour de l'improvisation théâtrale
aussi qu'on a développé de façon massive
dans les collèges de depuis 30 ans
puisqu'on a fêté les critères de la
fêter ses 30 ans donc il y a la fois ça
et puis effectivement l'émergence d'une
singularité d'un seul coup quelqu'un qui
veut aller un peu plus loin comment je
l'accompagne parce que on parle de Jamel
mais il a fallu six ans pour que Djamel
arrive à là où il devait être
c'est-à-dire de d'exploser donc pendant
ces 5 6 ans c'est comment effectivement
bon à papi ou un autre mais comment on
accompagne effectivement un talent
émergé et il y a besoin de temps de
rencontre avec le public et c'est ce
qu'on a décidé de faire avec la ville de
Trappes c'est de créer de recréer cet
espace là parce que je dis Omer écoute
Ali écoute je suis là moi ce que je sais
faire c'est accompagner des futurs
talents donc pourquoi et pourquoi pas
sur ce terroir trappiste mais voilà il y
a pratique et qui est Guyancourt parce
qu'elle a vu le dernier talent trap
chaud et donc elle est venue me voir et
puis c'était intéressant parce qu'elle
avait à nous dire je dis bah écoute
ouais bah là dans le prochain tu y es et
on travaille dessus donc c'est l'idée
pourquoi proposer c'est l'accompagnement
avant tous ces l'accompagnement avec un
point de départ un point d'étape qui est
bah celui de se retrouver de confronter
un public et puis se donner à voir se
faire entendre et puis qu'est-ce qui va
y avoir de particulier dans dans ce que
la personne va vous dire et si elle peut
être drôle alors là c'est carrément le
pompon donc
c'est un vrai bonheur de pouvoir mettre
ça en place attrape pour moi ça a
beaucoup de sens puisque avec tout le
travail que qu'on a pu faire c'est 30
dernières années bah ça continue et je
suis encore là toujours là la
transmission que s'est-il passé avant la
soirée comment et ont été sélectionnés
les talents qui seront sur scène
mercredi je vous ai dit à la fois il y a
quelqu'un comme pratique qui a vu le
dernier et puis qui est venu me voir à
la près il m'a dit comment et donc du
coup je l'ai reçu à Trappes pour pouvoir
travailler avec elle sur son sur ces 10
minutes qu'elle va faire et puis après
certains c'est des connaissances donc il
y a des gens qui sont plus rodés qui ont
qui ont de l'expérience comme Christine
Berrou qui va venir
après c'est les réseaux c'est aussi
effectivement je me suis fait un petit
nom aussi dans le milieu de l'humour
donc les gens pour eux c'est important
de venir attraper ça parce que c'est là
où il s'est passé plein de choses donc
même pour les dans le milieu du l'humour
trap reste une référence donc de venir
partager le plateau avec des débutants
pour des confirmer c'est aussi important
ce soir là il y aura des des premières
sur scène du coup alors il y a des
premières je vous parlais de pratique il
y aurait il y aura effectivement à la
fois des gens qui qui sont dans une
phase d'émergence c'est-à-dire qu'ils
ont déjà pratiqué ils ont déjà eu des
rencontres mais il faut encore les
accompagner donc donc il y a une qui
fait sa première c'est pointille après
il y a Steve ou Carla ou Marie ça va
être sa deuxième on va dire aussi et
puis qui ont une petite actualité qui se
lancent dans le métier donc et puis
après il y a Christine Berrou qui est un
peu plus de bouteilles et voilà à chaque
fois c'est
de dire il y a une progression enfin il
faut tenir c'est les métiers difficiles
où il faut s'accrocher il faut tenir il
faut manger mais bon les copains
sportifs nous verrons tout à l'heure
c'est pareil pour le sport donc la
détermine ne pas lâcher d'être de on
enclenche quelque chose et ben trappe
sera une étape le talent de trappe chaud
on sera une peut-être sur leur chemin et
tant mieux mais la détermination c'est
pas que dans le sport Audrey qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler tout à l'heure
pour ceux qui connaissent pas le format
ça se déroule comment concrètement la
soirée alors il y a cinq artistes et
puis les internets sont menés par moi et
Julie qui est qui est aussi la
coproductrice de de ce talent trap chaud
et on et donc on va laisser 5 entre 5 et
10 minutes à chaque talent pour pouvoir
exprimer ce qu'il a à dire ensuite on le
reçoit et on fait un débriefing avec lui
non pas de ce qui vient de se jouer mais
d'où il en est qu'est-ce qui veut
défendre et tout ça reste plus on vient
pas baiser le meilleur et tout ça
à l'issue de la soirée vainqueur voilà
il y a pas de vainqueur mais il y a cinq
talents qui ont un peu d'espace du temps
pour pouvoir se donner à voir et
l'accompagnement se poursuit après la
soirée on imagine du coup effectivement
attrape je suis en train de faire une
pépinière donc bah pour certains si je
peux les accompagner plus loin et ben je
le fais avec grand bonheur donc le
public pas de roulage à jouer ne
serait-ce que découvrir ses talents
finalement plaisir découvrir des talents
et le conservatoire est une vraie belle
coquille le son est comme c'est un
conservatoire il est très très bon donc
non c'est toujours très comment dire
c'est toujours touchant de voir aussi
des gens pour qui c'est les premiers pas
sur le plateau quoi info pratique billet
à 5 euros pour venir même pas cher pas
cher on peut le prendre à l'avance ou on
vient directement sur place on peut
aussi appeler mais on peut venir au
dernier moment en se disant tiens je
vais passer une bonne soirée et on le
disait donc tel en trap show c'est ce
mercredi 24 mai voilà c'est cette
semaine voilà ça tombe très bien à deux
jours de l'événement et ça se déroule au
Conservatoire de Musique et de Danse de
trap à partir de 20h30 merci papi être
venu en parler en plateau est-ce que
vous avez déjà créé autour de la table
des objets éco-responsables est-ce que
le Do It Yourself ça vous parle est-ce
que vous êtes déjà essayé Rodrigue pas
trop non
plus ah mais je bricole mais ça tient
pas forcément c'est le problème Gabriel
vous j'ai appris pendant le tournage du
sujet que vous allez voir justement à
faire des des sachets de thé
réutilisables
ça se multiplie il y a de plus en plus
d'adeptes en France c'est à dire
confectionner soi-même des objets grâce
à des matières en plus recyclées
créations qui peuvent être écologiques
qui peuvent être également ludiques et
vous l'avez dit vous avez fait un petit
peu le teasing vous avez assisté à la
création de de sachets de thé écologique
c'était lors de la dernière fête de la
transition écologique à Guyancourt
créer des objets du quotidien écologique
et donner une seconde vie aux matières
une préoccupation chez de plus en plus
de Français qui tentent d'adopter des
gestes éco-responsables des gestes
parfois tout simple comme la réalisation
de sachets de thé réutilisables c'est
réutilisable c'est lavable ça permet de
vraiment vraiment diminuer tous les
déchets que l'on peut avoir un sachet
thé c'est une seule utilisation là vous
aurez beaucoup plus d'utilisation et
pour réaliser ce sachet rien de plus
simple l'essentiel est dans vos tiroirs
alors vous avez besoin d'un tissu à
point de croix qui est un coton qui est
un coton bio voilà un peu de ruban pour
le rendre plus joli voilà et du fil
d'aiguille et d'un bouton cousue à la
main la conception du sachet dure une
vingtaine de minutes une activité
accessible aussi bien aux adultes qu'aux
enfants pour les Lucs qui réalisent ces
ateliers dans des associations et les
maisons de jeunesse de la ville il
s'agit d'un art créatif ludique et
écologique vous le découpez 9 sur 9 vous
mettez du ruban au-dessus pour que ça
soit joli voilà vous le retournez comme
ça voilà à l'envers bien sûr place
maintenant à la réalisation et on
commence avec un peu de couture en
positionne deux petites pinces faut
éviter que ça bouge et en couple pour
plus de solidité il est conseillé de
doubler l'épaisseur du fil prochaine
étape ajouter un joli ruban en guise de
fil de serrage une étape délicate on met
son aiguille alors c'est l'aiguille à
laine on prend deux trois trous et on
tire tout doucement
[Musique]
dernière touche finale pour notre sachet
de thé trouvé un bouton pour le refermer
le sachet est pour éviter qu'il tombe il
est maintenu avec avec des boutons ce
sont des boutons qu'on nous rapporte au
qu'on récupère sur nos vêtements que
l'on va jeter tout ça donc c'est un peu
des boutons dépareillés mais en fait
c'est le but le but est de récupérer les
boutons
et voilà et votre sachet thé est
terminée
après l'utilisation vous n'avez plus
qu'à le laisser sécher le laver avec du
liquide vaisselle ou à la machine avec
vos cotons démaquillants réutilisables
par exemple bien entretenu il peut se
conserver près d'un an
et on ouvre la page sport dans le 7 8
[Musique]
et dès le début de cette partie sport
turnover en plateau avec de nouvelles
personnes qui sont sur ce plateau il y a
donc toujours Jacques Boine le président
du MLS GP mais vous a été rejoint par
Baptiste lemmery bonsoir capitaine de
l'équipe senior du MLS GP et aussi vous
évoluer donc au poste de 2000 mêlés en
face de vous notre journaliste sport du
soir Nicolas dandry
78 on parle du MLSGP oui parce que le
mêle GP ça s'est assuré depuis hier va
évoluer la saison prochaine en fédéral 2
alors si vous me le permettez si le
président me le permet les mensonaux
Saint-Germain nous ici à qui vont
rejoindre Versailles et plaisir la crème
du rugby yvelinois les clubs des
Yvelines qui jouent au plus haut niveau
c'est la sixième division du rugby
national français
la nuit a été courte non
surtout quand on voit les images qui
vont s'afficher de l'ambiance qui avait
déjà à la fin du match au début du match
à la fin du match je suppose que la nuit
a été très courte même pour vous les
joueurs
Jacques nous disait tout à l'heure sa
réaction vous au lendemain vous sentez
comment Mathis 13 heureux très heureux
d'avoir réussi à faire remonter le club
en Fédérale 2 et fatigué aussi et alors
cet accession fait suite à cette
victoire contre l'US Cavaillon en 16e de
finale de Fédérale 3 au match aller dans
le Vaucluse vous étiez incliné 17 à 13
on voit les résultats qui s'affichent
lors du match retour hier à domicile
vous l'avez emporté 25 à 18 entre les
deux matchs dans quel état d'esprit vous
étiez parce que vous étiez en retard
comment ça s'est passé cette semaine
entre une victoire de part et d'autre
mais c'est la différence sur les deux
matchs bien sûr qui est pris mais c'est
pour ça que vous êtes qualifié
on était on était confiant on était
confiant parce qu'on avait fait un gros
match quand même à Cavaillon et qu'une
des de 4 points c'est assez facile à
récupérer et après voilà on a fait tout
ce qui tout ce qu'il fallait pour pour
gagner ce match à la maison et pouvoir
être qualifié la différence
je pense qu'on a rien lâché on a rien
lâché on a on a su apprendre de notre
défaite de l'année dernière et
ça nous a pas souri la dernière à une
seconde et là on a réussi dernière
seconde à mettre la pénalité qui nous a
refait passer devant et nous nous a
permis de nous qualifier donc je pense
que c'est sur ça c'est ça c'est
l'expérience président Jacob c'est quoi
la force de ce groupe force de ce groupe
c'est que
c'est une bombe de copains alors qui
sont peut-être découvert un peu sur le
tard même tout au long de la saison mais
c'est une bande de copains en fait et
contrairement à d'autres clubs où je
sais faire d'autres niveaux où on va
dire que l'aspect financier prend
de la place dans le dans la vie de tous
les jours dans un club bah là
aujourd'hui tout le monde est à peu près
sur le même piédestal en fait il y a pas
de il y a pas de star il y a un groupe
en fait donc ça ça gagne en groupe les
gens sont tous au même niveau et je
pense que c'est ce qui fait notre petit
notre petite réussite vous voulez dire
vous en êtes rendu compte en cette bande
de potes on est rendu compte au cours de
la saison qu'ils étaient vraiment pote
c'est à dire qu'il y a eu une évolution
tout au long de la saison où vous l'avez
senti aussi il y a une montée en
puissance il y a une montée en puissance
il y a des il y a des relations qui se
font vraiment naturellement on les voit
vivre alors surtout en plus moi j'étais
ancien joueur enfin il y a quelques
années je vois encore avec eux voilà
j'ai mis les crampons au placard mais ça
se voit dans leurs attitudes en fait et
d'un point de vue extérieur on voit une
bande de copains ensemble et c'est ce
qui fait vraiment avancer le le club
quoi vous confirmez Baptiste vous qui
avez vécu les choses de l'intérieur
aussi on le voit parce que après c'est
tout des petits détails qui qui au début
on va dire qu'on va peut-être rater
quelque part c'est après il y a les
automatismes mais on voit au cours de la
saison qu'on a beaucoup évolué et donc
l'année prochaine retour en Fédérale 2
est-ce que vous vous projetez déjà ou là
il y a encore on va dire l'euphorie de
cette qualification comment comment vous
projetez alors non il y a toujours le
Forex cette qualification mais il faut
déjà y penser il faut déjà mettre en
place tout ce qu'on va mettre en place
si on veut pas se prendre les pieds dans
le tapis parce qu'on va pas se mentir
l'objectif va être de se maintenir
l'année prochaine enfin dans cette
Fédérale 2 et de pas faire l'ascenseur
là-dessus d'arriver à monter et
descendre ça serait bien pour personne
donc l'objectif va être le maintien voir
un peu mieux si on peut se qualifier
pour efficace finale on verra ce qui est
à prendre mais voilà donc non ça
commence tout de suite à prendre des
contacts ce qu'avaient déjà été lancé
avant avec des joueurs avec enfin voilà
et d'encadrement enfin voilà pour
renforcer un petit peu le club mais dans
des niveaux raisonnables Nicolas on va
dire ça c'est la vision du président
parce que là il y a une qualification
pour la Fédérale de l'année prochaine
mais il y a une qualification
plutôt à court terme ce week-end vous
allez jouer en terrain neutre ça va être
différent des derniers matchs puisque
les derniers matchs étaient des phases
aller-retour un match à l'extérieur un
match à domicile là vous allez jouer en
terrain neutre et en plus pour ce vous
allez jouer les périgourdin de Sarlat
c'est costaud dans le Sud-Ouest non
c'est costaud mais on est très costaud
aussi dans la région parisienne et là
maintenant c'est que du bonus l'objectif
il y a plus de pression là maintenant on
joue et on va essayer d'aller au plus
loin justement vous allez préparer
comment ce match de ce week-end mais
comme tous les autres matchs c'est mais
là on sait c'est match coupe près c'est
un match on gagne on passe sinon fini on
rentre à la maison donc voilà c'est
peut-être le meilleur état d'esprit
c'est ça l'ange tout pour du bonus et du
plaisir et moi j'oublie pas que hier il
y a mon numéro 6 mon troisième ligne qui
m'a promis d'aller toucher le bout de
bois le 25 juin le jour de mon
anniversaire
et du coup comptez quand même sur le
soutien du supporter même si c'est sur
terrain neutre il y a comment vous allez
vous organiser pour essayer d'avoir
quand même un contingent avec vous on a
déjà commencé aujourd'hui on a bon bah
réservé le bus pour les joueurs
premièrement et on a déjà mis un quart
de supporters à disposition si on
remplit bien facilement qui est encore
de la demande j'en mettrai un deuxième
voilà après dans l'attrape pas plus
parce que vous savez le lieu ça devrait
être vers château on l'a pas encore
officiellement mais ça devrait être dans
la région c'est amis distance donc ça
devrait être Châteauroux donc on mettra
un bus voir deux bus de supporters pour
voilà continuer à faire vivre un petit
peu l'ambiance autour du club juste
quand même pour continuer à se projeter
quand même sur la saison prochaine quand
voilà la saison de Versailles qui comme
vous l'année dernière accéder en
Fédérale 2 depuis la Fédérale 3 on voit
qu'ils sont arrivés jusqu'en final c'est
quand même prometteur peut-être pour
vous c'est une différence c'est que
Versailles pour la première fois cette
saison en Fédérale de alors pouvez-vous
c'est un retour c'était il y a 10 ans
donc bon c'est comme le vélo ça s'oublie
pas mais bon on va faire quand même les
joueurs ont changé c'est plus la même
époque enfin voilà il va falloir se
remettre à la page aussi un petit peu
là-dedans mais ce qui est encourageant
c'est que l'année dernière on jouait
contre Versailles on Fédérale 3
on a eu une victoire chacun et on a fini
à très peu de points de la première
place derrière Versailles alors je pense
vous êtes un petit peu supérieur à nous
faut pas le mentir mais on n'est pas si
loin que ça donc pourquoi pas me suivre
le même chemin que et d'arriver à faire
une belle première saison Fédérale 2 ils
l'ont fait on était à peu près au même
niveau on peut le faire on se souvient
un gros ambiance dans ces derby Vinois
ça a été aussi le cassette cette saison
Fédérale 2 entre plaisir et Versailles
Rodrigue vous qui suivez le sport
Illinois même si vous êtes plutôt du
côté de football comme pour quel regard
vous portez sur un une telle prestation
telle performance on est toujours très
fier d'avoir des clubs Yvelines au
niveau surtout au rugby je trouve que
vous êtes super performance et c'est
très très bien donc je pense que c'est
dû aussi au travail de formation qui a
fait en amont
tout à fait son truc comme ça c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure avant
l'émission il y a 550 licenciés donc
dans ces 150 licenciés il y a
tout ce qui est l'école de rugby
d'accord avec nos jeunes aux juniors et
un club a besoin d'une bonne école de
rugby et c'est je pense une chose sur
lequel on doit travailler encore un
petit peu plus si on veut continuer à
avancer et arriver à équilibrer le club
il va falloir mettre un petit peu plus
de moyens sur notre école de rugby parce
que c'est quand même notre premier
vivier pour enfin qu'on a des juniors
qui sortent pour renforcer l'équipe
première mais c'est gagné en fait
l'objectif il est là quoi
dernière saison pour moi
l'année prochaine l'année prochaine donc
il y aura une saison pour vous en
Fédérale 2 effectivement
35 ans bon en tout cas merci messieurs
bravo bravo à vous bravo MLS GP pour
cette promotion en Fédérale 2 et on va
suivre la fin de saison on l'espère avec
une arrivée le plus loin impossible dans
ces phases finales de Fédérale 3
sur le plateau
donc là on parle d'une montée de
fédérale grand Fédérale 2 et on continue
de parler de rugby on descend encore
d'un échelon cette fois-ci oui c'est ça
régional une anciennement honneur le
Club Athlétique de Chevreuse c'est
qualifié en 8e du final de de ce
championnat ce dimanche 21 mai en
terrain neutre à Massy les chevrotins se
sont imposés face à Créteil sur le score
de 43 à 20 et pourtant la rencontre
avait très mal débuté pour eux
et on va regarder Nicolas le récit
humain de France de régional une comme
les Rochelais dans leur finale
européenne face aux Irlandais du
Leicester les chevrotins encaissent un
17 à 0 contre Créteil dans les 20
premières minutes de la rencontre une
pénalité et deux essais encaissés la
domination est sans partage
on est rentré sur le terrain à mort quoi
et eux c'est arrivé plein d'envies on
s'est fait voilà on s'est fait rouler
dessus pendant 20 minutes quoi il y a
pas grand chose à dire on a on a mis la
main sur le ballon comme il l'avait fait
et après on a pu avancer et dérouler le
jeu donc on a pas le ballon c'est
compliqué quoi les Yvelines vont
finalement se réveiller il franchissent
une première fois la ligne en force
et sur une belle inspiration l'ailier de
Chevreuse fait la différence
[Applaudissements]
les chevrotins recollent au score à la
mi-temps ils ont 6 points de retard
Créteil mènent 20 à 14 au retour des
vestiaires Chevreuse garde la même
dynamique le rouleau compresseur
Chevrotin est enclenché
les Yvelines définitivement l'avantage
grâce à cet essai 20 à 24
Chevreuse prend même le large en fin de
match jusqu'à s'imposer sur le score de
43 à 20
en deuxième mi temps là on n'a pas lâché
les 30 et on a réussi à revenir sur les
fondamentaux quoi vraiment devant avec
deux essais sur ballon porté et voilà
quoi on arrive à trouver deux bonnes
sorties de camp après et après surtout
de se faire plaisir quoi de mettre du
combat parce que le rugby ça commence
par le combat et si on en met pas on
gagnera pas de match quoi donc ils ont
décidé eux en deuxième mi-temps de
mettre du combat et voilà en 8e de
finale de régionale une Chevreuse
affrontera l'us-sainte rugby un club de
Charente-Maritime qui sera forcément
gonflé à bloc après le titre de champion
d'Europe de La Rochelle les chevrotins
sont prévenus
bon Baptiste Jacques Chevreuse qui est
promis en Fédérale 3 le rugby Vinois est
à la fête là cette saison oui oui c'est
bien c'est on les avait rencontrés en
honneur et on avait on est content
qu'ils montent aussi un Fédérale 3 donc
ça peut permettre d'avoir une équipe
supplémentaire à ce niveau vous qui
quittez donc ce niveau parce que vous
allez évoluer la saison prochaine en
Fédérale 2 on continue les résultats
sports de ce weekend Nicolas avec
notamment du football et le premier tour
de la Coupe de France effectivement
Grégory un premier tour qui rassemble
les clubs du niveau départemental j'ai
sélectionné les clubs des 12 communes de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines regardez Voisins-le-Bretonneux
s'est imposé 3,2 à l'extérieur victoire
à domicile pour Montigny-le-Bretonneux 5
bus à 2 et Guyancourt 4 bus à 3 quoi
longtemps porté à l'extérieur plaisir et
le seul club 50 chinois être éliminé au
premier tour une défaite 5 1
et je salue moi mes coéquipiers de
Jouy-en-Josas qualification également au
premier tour de cette Coupe de France on
va poursuivre avec du baseball cette
fois-ci une grosse performance une
victoire historique avec un grand H les
Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux ont
remporté le Challenge de France de
baseball c'est une première des animaux
teint se sont imposés sur le score de 9
manches à 4 face au husky de Rouen les
cougars décroches par la même occasion
leur ticket pour le championnat européen
c'est la deuxième fois de leur histoire
qui participe à cet événement enfin à ce
championnat qui participeront l'année
prochaine à ce championnat européen à
noter que le lanceur de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux originaire du
Venezuela York Lopez a été nommé MVP de
la compétition bravo alu bravo au cougar
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux un résultat de
handball féminin à présent oui 22e et
dernière journée du championnat de
National 2 les inhymontaines ont emporté
à domicile dans leur antre du gymnase de
Pierre de Coubertin une victoire 29 à 27
contre Corbie au classement les
féminines de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
termine à la CIN quième place de leur
poule on termine avec un résultat de
tennis de table et oui du ping-pong
Grégory je sais que vous adorez ça la
balle d'or la compétition phare du
comité départemental des Yvelines je ne
vous y ai pas vu Grégory
s'est déroulé ce samedi 20 et dimanche
21 le gymnase des droits de l'homme un
tournoi qui a rassemblé 416 participants
âgées de 7 ans à plus de 60 ans il n'y a
pas d'âge pour faire du ping-pong venant
des 63 clubs du département le
département des Yvelines c'est le
troisième comité départemental et bien
de France parmi les participants
plusieurs sont classés dans le top 1000
des joueurs français regarder on a
recueilli quelques réactions
[Musique]
et point faible il y a pas il se
décourage vite pour moi c'est une
compétition c'est une chance de gagner
des matchs de rencontrer d'autres
personnes et de surtout de m'amuser
c'est la compétition de référence en
fait celle qui permet de détecter les
futurs talents celle qui permet de voir
les progrès qui ont été faits pendant
l'année pour les jeunes et celles qui
permet à tous nos adhérents de se
rencontrer d'une manière tout à fait
conviviale on est un département qui
fait beaucoup de détections c'est-à-dire
qu'on a de très bon jeunes
malheureusement après il s'en vont dans
des clubs qui ont plus de moyens que les
nôtres donc ils nous quittent mais on a
deux joueurs qui évoluent en National
de beaux résultats sportifs peut-être
conséquences d'une grande détermination
parce que dans le monde du sport mais
pas que aussi dans le monde du travail
en général dans la vie en général c'est
une valeur très importante et justement
vous en parlez dans votre livre de la
détermination Rodrigue MBC je rappelle
que vous êtes coach à l'Étoile Sportive
de trap et vous venez de publier ce
livre on va peut-être voir la couverture
s'afficher je suis coach depuis le début
un livre voilà où vous racontez comment
vous avez utilisé votre détermination
pour atteindre vos objectifs vivre aussi
de votre passion le tout au travers de
votre parcours pourquoi écrire ce livre
pourquoi le dédier
à cette vie de coach finalement pas tout
simplement parce qu'en fait j'ai
l'habitude de faire beaucoup de choses
depuis de nombreuses années surtout être
très investi au sein de l'Étoile
Sportive de Trappes en effet d'où je
suis responsable de section féminine
catégorie maintenant c'est la section
féminine que je que je gère depuis
maintenant de depuis 2014 donc en fait
j'avais besoin de passer un message et
surtout de formaliser des choses donc en
écrivant ce livre en fait on va
découvrir un peu mon parcours mes
ambitions et aussi
comment j'en suis arrivé là en fait et
un choix fort celui de vous orienter
vers une carrière de coach à seulement
13 ans on en parlait tout à l'heure en
off quand on joue au football ou même
qu'on pratique un sport c'est vrai qu'à
cet âge là on pense pas forcément à
devenir tout de suite entraîneur vous
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé à l'époque dans votre adolescence
à vous dire j'ai envie de devenir coach
en fait ce qui est très drôle c'est que
moi j'ai été détecté très très jeune et
en fait j'ai toujours été intéressé par
ces questions de management
d'organisation et et avoir la main sur
un groupe tout simplement et ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'en fait
moi là je joue mes copains voulaient
devenir des joueurs professionnels et
ben moi j'étais attiré attiré par les
grands coachs italiens à l'époque des
coachs comme j'ai vu débuter notre amour
de chez nautique
toujours aujourd'hui en plus ce qui est
un exemple qui est un exemple et puis et
puis voilà tout simplement les coachs
italiens arrivent aussi Marcello Lippi
voilà pour vous prêchez un convaincu
Rodrigue je sais pas moi bâti vous
pensez à entraîner après ou pas du tout
pourquoi pas pour pas ça peut être une
bonne solution pour continuer dans le
rugby mais c'est vrai que c'est insolite
de se dire des 13 ans on va entrer
au rugby il fallait que je joue et vous
Jacques vous êtes déjà entraîné non non
mais
je pense pas je pense qu'il faut comme
tu le dis enfin c'est il faut avoir la
fibre il faut vraiment avoir envie de de
faire partager ses émotions avec un
groupe alors moi je fais différemment
avec ton président mais de l'être sur le
terrain tout le temps avec le groupe
c'est vrai que c'est plus comme Baptiste
c'est pour jouer quoi en fait plus pour
jouer pour encadrer quoi tout à fait
là-dessus donc c'est un choix fort vous
avez fait à vos 13 ans et on imagine le
parcours derrière n'a pas été simple
quels sont les obstacles qui ont pu qui
ont pu se trouver sur le chemin depuis
ce choix à 13 ans en fait j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir été bien bien entouré et
bien encadré en fait moi j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir un de mes situation
d'écoles qui m’avait détecté à l'école
et en fait qui m'a qui suivait mon
parcours et puis en fait ça a commencé
par une discussion anodine en fait c'est
qu'en fait un jour j'étais convoqué pour
mon premier match de la saison en fait
il y avait un plateau débutant qui se
déroulait et en fait on a pris
énormément de retard donc le coach nous
donne l'ordre de débarrasser le terrain
pour qu'on débarrasse le terrain là à
tout ça et puis je me retrouve en face
du responsable des débutants et je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé je me suis il
faut que je lui pose cette question et
je lui demande en fait instinctivement
comment on fait pour devenir coach donc
lui il me dit bah c'est très simple
rendez-vous mercredi prochain 13h30 et
donc là vous êtes présenté le mercredi
d'après tout à fait donc et ça a débuté
donc mon professeur d'école en fait en
changeant d'emploi en fait on se
retrouve directeur technique
départemental donc bah ça tombe très
bien parce qu'il m'a un programme en
place en fait de jeunes éducateurs pour
relancer des la filière et en fait je
bénéficie de ce parcours là en fait donc
l'accompagnement et aujourd'hui c'est
pour vous c'est une valeur qui vous est
cher aussi de pouvoir transmettre à
votre tour indispensable un
indispensable parce que comme je disais
tout à l'heure j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
été accompagné et moi aujourd'hui dans
mon mode de fonctionnement le fait de
retrans de retransmettre et de
retranscrire ce qu'on m'a donné et super
important cette valeur très très forte
et on peut citer notamment dans notre
parcours vous êtes titulaire d'un brevet
d'état d'éducateur sportif option
football ça c'est depuis 2009 c'est ça
parce que dans le cheminement en fait il
y a pour pouvoir entraîner il y a il y a
des diplômes tout à fait donc il y a des
diplômes mais surtout pour devenir
salarié parce qu'en fait moi pour être
salarié pour pouvoir arrêter salarié au
club de trappe mais il a fallu que je
passe tous mes diplômes et surtout avoir
de brevet d'état pour pouvoir être
rémunéré en tant que moniteur de
football en fait le brevet d'état c'est
ce qui permet la rémunération c'est ça
c'est le premier diplôme qui permet
d'être rémunéré pour pas baby du
football en fait et vous le dites donc
la clé de la réussite on en parlait tout
à l'heure c'est la détermination la la
persévérance même si la la seule
motivation ça suffit pas finalement non
ça suffit pas parce qu'en fait ce que
pense certains c'est qu'en disant par
exemple ben j'ai envie de faire quelque
chose on pense que ça suffit non ça ne
suffit pas en fait il faut mettre un
plan il faut avoir une discipline une
rigueur et surtout une vision c'est
surtout ça que je veux faire transmettre
aux gens c'est qu'il faut avoir une
vision et de super passionné par rapport
à ce qu'on va faire et surtout se donner
vraiment des moyens de ses ambitions et
du coup dans ce livre vous donner vos
secrets il y a les moyens de d'établir
un plan si je puis dire en tout cas moi
dans ce livre je transmets mon plan ça a
fonctionné pour moi moi je suis
convaincu que ça pour fonctionner pour
tout le monde pour les coach d'ailleurs
ça peut être dans le monde professionnel
en général tout simplement en fait
l'idée c'est vraiment quand on a un
projet c'est de planifier de se donner
les moyens et puis surtout pas d'aller
au bout de tes objectifs tout simplement
Nicolas ça va au delà du sport
finalement le livre ça peut servir aussi
à des chefs d'entreprise des personnes
qui sont engagées dans des associations
tout à fait aussi d'accord et est-ce que
après ce livre quels sont vos objectifs
maintenant pas pour être honnête avec
vous ce livre en fait est fait partie
d'un plan voilà il fait partie de votre
propre
donc en fait bah j'ai 25 ans
quasiment d'expérience au mandat dans le
monde amateur au niveau du football donc
je pense que je dois pareil pour
m'éclater m'épanouir pas ouvrir d'autres
horizons donc je suis très intéressé par
l'univers de la conférence en fait donc
en fait par rapport à ce livre
j'aimerais justement continuer à
divulguer ce message et surtout
permettre aux gens d'atteindre des
objectifs tout simplement et vous parlez
de football amateur ça vous a attiré
d'aller pourquoi pas vers le monde
professionnel ou vous le football
amateur c'est une valeur qui vous est
cher aussi je pense que le football
amateur est une est une valeur très très
importante pour moi parce qu'en fait
c'est là qu'on en fait au football
surtout dans le club où je suis
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un prétexte
pour faire passer des messages bon
aujourd'hui par rapport à ma section
féminine par exemple j'encourage des
filles à prendre le responsabilités donc
je leur fais comprendre de ce qu'elles
font déjà ce n'est pas facile et
deuxièmement faut qu'elle prenne leur
place c'est super important et donc pour
suivre ce livre avec pourquoi pas des
conférences pour continuer de prêcher si
je puis dire cette bonne parole de la
détermination qui peut conduire au
succès juste sur
ça a été facile de raconter son parcours
c'est c'est du travail a pris combien de
temps pour restituer tout ça donc en
fait il y a un travail de 4 à 5 mois
quand même donc au départ j'ai beaucoup
de mal à me lancer parce que c'est vrai
que je suis quelqu'un de très réservé
malgré l'accord que j'ai en penses que
je suis méchant très très réservé et
puis en fait j'ai réussi à découler mon
style d'écriture parce qu'en fait j'ai
voulu faire un cadeau en fait en fait ce
livre est un cadeau que je fais à mes
adhérents à ma femme à mon fils à mes
frères ah bah tous ceux qui me
connaissent entre guillemets j'ouvre une
nouvelle facette une nouvelle facette
que je propose à tout le monde quoi et
ce cadeau c'est je suis coach depuis le
début le nom de cet ouvrage qu'on peut
se procurer où on peut le trouver où
donc comme c'est un livre que pareil
toujours dans leur histoire de plan donc
en fait il est autodidité d'accord donc
j'ai j'ai signé avec l'entreprise BOD
donc bod.fr donc il est disponible à la
vente et puis on est référencé chez tous
les bons tous les bons livrés et vous en
êtes donc l'auteur Rodrigue et mizi
merci d'être venu parler en plateau de
ce livre donc je suis coach depuis le
début on va revenir à présent dans le 7
8 sur cet événement qui se tenait samedi
la Fédération française de cyclotourisme
organisait des événements sportifs pour
les 10-18 ans à Rambouillet environ 170
cyclistes tu sais essayer à des épreuves
de maniabilité d'orientation ou
participer à un concours d'éducation
routière l'objectif des développer la
bonne pratique du vélo pour améliorer
l'autonomie sur la route le reportage de
Julien Leroy Mathilde Franco et de vous
Nicolas dandry
une journée ensoleillée pour les
passionnés du vélo la Fédération
Française de cycles tourisme organisait
ce samedi 20 mai à La Bergerie Nationale
de Rambouillet des événements à
destination des jeunes le critérium
national 2023 proposé au 135 sportifs
âgés de 13 à 18 ans de se défier autour
de différentes compétitions ou vers au
licencier les écoles françaises de vélo
cette expérience permettait de
développer l'autonomie et d'adopter un
comportement citoyen en randonnée il y a
une épreuve de maniabilité donc VTT et
routes il y a eu une épreuve à rallye
donc ils vont faire un parcours de 30 à
40 km il y a une course d'orientation il
y a des questions générales donc c'est
vraiment la tête et les jambes et puis
il y a une épreuve de mécanique pour
l'orientation les jeunes venus de toute
la France devaient retrouver différentes
balises réparties dans la commune sur un
parcours d'environ 3 km et tout ça ça
leur rapporte des points ils ont un
total de 840 à chaque fois qu'ils
trouvent pas de balises ou qui font des
fautes en maniabilité ou dans les
questions ça leur retire des points donc
l'objectif c'est d'avoir un maximum de
points parallèle de cet événement la
Fédération proposait le concours
national d'éducation routière pour 46
listes âgés de 10 à 12 ans objectif
reprendre les bases de la maniabilité et
du code de la route pour améliorer sa
pratique du vélo
QCM slalom est position statique ou
parfois poser les difficultés aux jeunes
sportifs
j'ai pas trop réussi à répondre le
premier atelier les virages cérébent
parce que j'ai dû recommencer trois fois
c'est aussi de la convivialité c'est des
régions qui se rencontrent voilà donc
c'est ça et de faire que ces jeunes là
finissent par devenir adhérents à la
Fédération Française de vélo la
Fédération française de cyclotourisme
regroupe environ 100000 membres avec une
majorité de licencie retraités la
structure espère rajeunir sa moyenne
d'âge en organisant d'autres événements
cyclistes à destination des adolescents
un résultat sport qui vient de nous
parvenir Nicolas en tennis
Vinois Antoine guibaudeau jeune nigliou
a de 18 ans du tennis donc dans les
phases de qualification de Roland Garros
c'est incliné face à Norbert gombos le
Slovaque de 32 ans 217ème mondial c'est
incliné sur le score de 7,6 63 600 donc
il a néanmoins remporté le premier set
face à au 217ème Mondial Antoine du Bono
pépite Yves linoise qui avait déjà
discuté Roland-Garros junior et c'était
une première pour lui sur le tour de
qualification du tournoi principal il
avait bénéficié d'une Walker
c'est-à-dire d'une invitation pour
pouvoir participer à ce tour de
qualification de Roland-Garros on aura
l'occasion de revenir sur les autres
yvelinois engagées notamment Caroline
Garcia qui notamment entretient les
espoirs français sur le tableau féminin
rencontre à présent pour refermer cette
page sport avec Véronique Chaplin à
l'occasion du 32e team break cette
compétition de golf qui est réunie de
grands sportifs français mais qui permet
surtout à les enfants venus de quartier
défavorisés de rencontrer leurs idoles
de partager aussi avec eux des bons
conseils sur le plan sportif des valeurs
aussi qui accompagnent ces ce plan
sportif dans le domaine de la nutrition
aussi de l'hygiène de vie notamment pour
les conseils qui sont prodigués le
parcours exemplaire d'une ancienne
grande joueuse de tennis qui a consacré
sa vie aux autres
alors si break est né parce que j'ai
démarré ma carrière chez Nike France il
y avait la chance d'être directrice
communication et marketing passionné de
tennis j'ai joué à Roland-Garros
et je rencontrais des sportifs de haut
niveau de sport comme le tennis le
football etc qui gagnait très bien leur
vie mais à côté de ça j'avais en
partenariat des champions d'athlétisme
de triathlon de boxe qui était déjà
extraordinaires qui avaient une histoire
à raconter et qui gagnait pas bien leur
vie et je me suis dit il faudra trouver
une occasion sur terrain ne rassembler
des champions des personnalités
sportives de toutes discipline et quoi
mieux que
Roland-Garros puisque moi j'étais
passionnée j'étais directement voir le
directeur de Roland-Garros et je lui
donnais cette idée je lui dis un grand
tournoi il y a des joueurs qui se
mettent au vert pendant la semaine de
calife le golf c'est un espace
magnifique pour se concentrer pour
l'agilité etc si nous organisions un
événement sur terrain neutre avec les
joueurs de Roland-Garros et des
champions
le directeur de Roland Garros a tout de
suite validé mon guide en me demandant
de d'organiser l'événement à cautionner
depuis 32 ans voilà il m'a permis
d'utiliser label Roland-Garros et de
m'ouvrir les portes de Roland-Garros on
a accueilli les champions et l'histoire
de tibrac est née en 1992
alors pour durer 30 ans je pense que je
suis bretonne chez quatre grands-parents
bretons il faut beaucoup de
pugnacité et moi j'ai une philosophie
c'est que je garde le sourire et je ne
montre que le meilleur je vais pas
raconter tous les offres c'est pas
facile c'est même compliqué il y a des
moments de désespoir de l'arme des
moments où on est déçu mais je me dois
pour ces enfants de continuer et
systématiquement dès que je suis avec
mes amis champions ou avec ces jeunes
leur sourire leur enthousiasme etc ce
côté spontané que moi j'ai peut-être
trop en tant que femme adulte
la machine repart automatiquement donc
il faut garder son cap et il faut
essayer d'être voilà d'être réglo avec
les gens qui nous aident et puis aussi
dire que la vie c'est aussi de la joie
de la bonne humeur il faut passer outre
toutes ces difficultés se dire voilà on
se fait des moments de trèfle justement
pour ces jeunes on oublie tout l'espace
d'une journée d'une semaine etc on se
mobilise pour ses enfants et tous les
gens patristes tu viens enfin tous les
gens qui viennent sortent de là
énergisée avec un sourire extraordinaire
[Musique]
alors il va se passer qu'on va
accueillir
une centaine de jeunes de collèges aussi
bien des Yvelines de Achères de
Sarcelles qui vont
tourner autour de 8 ateliers encadrés
par des champions
box tennis rugby foot volley judo basket
yoga et tout ce qui est respiration
prévention santé et puis l'atelier
nutrition avec nos grands chefs parce
que c'est très important la façon de
s'alimenter et en parallèle les
champions les personnalités vont faire
une compétition amicale de golf par
équipe avec ce fameux titre de champion
des champions sur un très beau parcours
avec un trou en un récompensé par Audi
Bauer donc et beaucoup de bonne humeur
et tous ces champions une fois la
compète de golf fini viennent vers les
enfants et c'est la fête avant les
enchères caritatives
[Musique]
Simon me demande toujours comment tu
arrives à avoir des lots aussi
magnifiques que le maillot de camavinga
de la Ligue des Champions celui de
Benzema offert par Didier Deschamps la
raquette de Federer moi je baigne dans
le milieu du sport et en fait toute
l'année avec SOS gazelles je suis en
contact avec ses champions je suis une
passionnée de tous les sports je suis
une passionnée de l'esprit de l'éthique
qui règne et du coup je les côtoie je
fais du coaching mental aussi donc je
donne un coup de main au quotidien et
ben quand on donne on reçoit et pour me
remercier ces champions qui savent que
cette cause est très importante nous
offre des maillots collector qui ont
marqué l'histoire du sport
et interview complète concernant le
tibray qui a retrouvé dès à présent sur
le site internet de TV 78 TV 78.com
avant de vous laisser on va jeter un
dernier coup d'oeil aux prévisions météo
de demain
le temps devrait se dégrader légèrement
demain matin dans les Yvelines un ciel
nuageux est annoncé fera 14 degrés dans
le nord et l'ouest du département 13
degrés à l'est et au sud quelques rayons
de soleil pourrait faire leur apparition
dans l'après-midi côté température
prévoyait 18 degrés à Versailles et ou
dans 19 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et 20
degrés à Rambouillet
voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci
Baptiste merci Jacques merci Rodrigue
merci Nicolas et d'avoir été avec moi
pour cette édition nouvelle édition du 7
8 à retrouver dès demain sur TV 78 belle
soirée à tous
[Musique]